[Musik]
der film eine ganz neue ordnung auf der
baustelle für das neue kinderspital mich
ein großer 20 22 wird gerät mit blauen
und dasselbe ruft er geriert punkt warum
tatsächlich dass wir jetzt absolut
schönsten und besten kinderspital auf
der kurzen seite direkt gesehen habe ich
gar nichts das spital ist viel holz ganz
viele sachen für hin zum entdecken kurze
werk und die individualisierte zimmer
ein buch als asp war nicht im ersten
moment ins spital wo das man vorher klar
rentiert mit
wo genau und das muss platziert dass ich
den hof vermerkt was aber sicheres wird
fürs neue kinderspital auch in literatur
lg was es tatsächlich im zentrum vom
spital über zwei stockwerke in ruhe mit
der öffnung im himmel und der himmel ist
übrigens blau
aber wer mit dem ruhm mit kunstlicht
farbig machten wachsen
der himmel klar wenn der ruhm pink
später himmel berühren wenn der ruhm
gehören wird dann wird der himmel pink
und der himmel umso mehr realisiert das
ist ein eigener erfolg aber eiskalt ein
wolken ballett wie dieses wird man dann
im neuen kinderspital immer wieder
beobachten können
sky spaces wie in zürich einer entstehen
wird gibt es an über 50 orten von
tasmanien bis italien
räume unterschiedlichster art die ein
laden mit den augen in himmels welten
einzutauchen
der neue sky space wird am 17 september
im österreichischen lech am arlberg
eröffnet auf 1800 metern
umgeben von hochalpiner kulisse fernab
urbaner lichtverschmutzung
man verlässt die bergwelt und geht durch
einen langen tunnel eine bewegliche
kuppel öffnet den blick für den himmel
[Musik]
die erste skizze die james turell für
den sky space in licht gezeichnet hat
ein raum angepasster landschaft
eingegraben in einen hügel
[Musik]
letzten sommer begannen die bauarbeiten
für den kunstraum der dem nobel-skiort
lech eine weitere touristische
attraktion bieten wird finanziert von
einem privaten verein wer hier die
symbiose von kunst und landschaft sucht
[Musik]
der sky space in lech wird zu jeder
jahreszeit zugänglich sein
im inneren soll eine licht installation
die kuppe in farben tauchen und so eine
ständig wechselnde perspektive auf
himmel und terence lichtfeld ermöglichen
[Musik]
letzten winter stapfte james turrell
selbst durch den schnee ähnlich um zu
sehen wie weit die arbeiten an seinem
space gediehen waren
das wird sehr gut aussehen
[Musik]
und was dann hoffentlich passiert je
nach wetter je nachdem ob der himmel
wolkig ist aber klar werden
unterschiedliche bilder entstehen wenn
jeder tag ist unterschiedlich jeden tag
jede sekunde ein anderes bild ein
ständiger übergang in etwas das man nie
für möglich gehalten hätte james turell
will uns das sehen bei bringen
die wahrnehmung für wolken bilden
den himmel fassbar machen für unsere
fantasie damit das was man sieht nicht
weit weg liegt sondern ganz nah
[Musik]
jetzt aber zurück auf der baustelle
kinderspital mich ein großer busen oder
mais kann also ziemlich genau wo wir
jetzt stehen aber einfach oben über zwei
stockwerke mit der öffnung der himmel
öffnete ich in der nachbarschaft von der
plattform wo der helikopter landet das
ist nicht ganz so einfach will man den
mechanismus dass man dann immer wenn der
heilig und stach zu gott also denn ich
denke die meisten in dem moment gelte es
anders geht mit unserem dach
lichtinstallation wo auch spezialist
oder himmel sich mit dem clean momentum
man sich vorstelle missstände jetzt da
und sie die tiefgarage und der ist dann
die meisten texte von gebäuden ein
bisschen gefangen
man merkt dass nicht einmal ganz normale
tür macht die tür auf und dann ist man
inneren andere welt von harry potter im
kreis nun drei viertel weiß gar nicht ob
das wirklich stimme hat weil man wieder
duschen ist und versuche ich zu
überprüfen
nochmal zum nur gelb sah ich ein
anarchistisches normal ich bedaure als
die trips um 3 andre ward kunsthof
stellen wie finanzieren sie der himmel
die hand glücklicher wies auf das
herzstück habe sie kunst begeistert die
töne faszinieren mit deren idee und mir
hand klirrend kalt könne zusammenbringen
zum das ermöglichen für den bau des
novitas geraten
meist kämen jährlich nehmen der himmel
hat im kinderspital nochmal ganz andere
spezielle politik ja forum will der
himmel für alle gültigkeit hat für alle
kultur für alle religionen für alle
schichten mir krimis um origins hat
james turell kürzlich ein herzinfarkt
erlitten haben wir vorher gehört muss in
die eigene kraft reserve arzt versorgt
sagen
es ist eben gar zum glück hat sich
situation stabilisiert das geht jeden
tag besser und alle sind guter dinge